Wanting computers are mentor just problems that cannot be addressed
by classical computers things
like finding the right materials to enable
carbon capture to really
bring the fight to climate change to address
more efficient fertilizers that can
not harm the earth but also continue the
food supply chain that we need to feed the world
also there's some fundamental questions of how our universe
is stitch together and how matter behaves at the atomic
and subatomic levels that we need to know
it's the next front here
let's take one area research already under way
the search for new batteries
batteries have transformed our lives by allowing us to carry
computers and smart phones
but there's more to be done batteries are crucial
to our clean energy future
whether it's powering electric cars really
pushing renewable energy
we need a fundamentally different chemistry
to create the batteries
for tomorrow one computing
would allow us to effectively look inside the battery
during its very complex reactions to enable us to
think about new materials
and the structure of the batteries that are going to be needed
to power the next generation of devices
how do we get there by building the world's most advanced content
devices and a developmental platform
and making it available to the world
only by working together now
will we be able to solve the problems that will be facing
together in the future.